tras el total colapso de la unión
soviética en 1991 la rusia comandada por
boris yeltsin parecía iniciar en un
primer momento una transición hacia lo
que podemos denominar valores
occidentales esto es la asunción de una
economía de mercado en el marco de
instituciones democráticas sin embargo
este proceso fue un auténtico desastre y
la corrupción los intereses de una
oligarquía que cada día se enriquecía
más y más con la liquidación del estado
y por qué no decirlo también la falta de
tacto y visión de occidente al no
otorgar largos y el peso merecido ni
colaborar con ella en este proceso
provocaron una debacle económica y
social generalizada en el gigante ruso
no hay nada mejor para los traficantes
de armas que el plan del soldados
descontentos y depósitos llenos de armas
y así llegamos al 31 de diciembre de
1999 momento en el que mediante un
anuncio sorpresa emitido a las 12 de la
noche boliviensis dimitió como
presidente de rusia y le pasó el testigo
al por aquel entonces relativamente
desconocido
vladimir putin un ex agente de la caja
que llegó con una misión clara luchar
porque la madre rusia recobra su estatus
de gran potencia mundial
para lograrlo putin ha cometido un
cambio de modelo y decidí un nuevo
sistema basado en un crecimiento del
poder militar una mayor influencia
internacional la concentración del poder
en manos del líder el impulso destacado
fervor nacionalista y la recuperación de
valores tradicionales como la familia o
la iglesia gracias al boom del petróleo
y las materias primas
putin contó además con importantísimos
recursos extras que le ayudaron a llevar
a cabo sus planes por ejemplo desde el
año 2003
rusia ha invertido la friolera de 750
mil millones de dólares en la
modernización de sus fuerzas armadas
pero dicho esto vamos a ver cuáles son
las claves de la política exterior rusa
y la explicación a su creciente
hostilidad con las potencias
occidentales porque como veremos no se
trata de una cuestión de testosterona o
de ambición de poder sino de una
estrategia de seguridad y defensa
perfectamente definidas
la defensa nacional
y luz ya no tiene fronteras naturales lo
que conduce a que su política de
seguridad y defensa esté muy
influenciada por el riesgo de invasión
algo que además está muy presente en la
conciencia colectiva dada las
experiencias históricas vividas desde la
invasión de los mongoles ya por el siglo
13 hasta la última de la alemania nazi
pasando por la invasión de napoleón para
responder a ese riesgo el planteamiento
de seguridad nacional apuesta por la
creación de las llamadas zonas bases o
espacios de seguridad entre rusia y sus
enemigos potenciales en otras palabras
moscú considera absolutamente necesario
para su seguridad controlar a sus
vecinos evitando de esta forma que
puedan ser hostiles a los intereses que
se acerquen a occidente o que adquieran
de facto plena autonomía veteranos sois
nuestro modelo habéis contribuido con
vuestro ejemplo moral a devolver el
crimen sebastopol a su patria pues
proyectiles por ello en la política de
seguridad rusa contempla tres escenarios
de intervención prioritaria por un lado
el antiguo grupo de repúblicas
soviéticas de europa oriental
ucrania bielorrusia y ojo la repúblicas
bálticas por otro el cáucaso y asia
central y finalmente por último el
pacífico
pero de forma concreta que amenazas
observamos q pues tanto la estrategia de
seguridad nacional como el plan de
desarrollo estratégico 2020 y la
doctrina militar en vigor definen que
los mayores riesgos pasan precisamente
por que eeuu y la unión europea consigan
cambiar el equilibrio de poder en las
mencionadas zonas de influencia natural
como mediante la ampliación de la otan y
el impulso al comercio libre y la
integración económica y de fibras él las
impulsa en el desarrollo de un nuevo
acuerdo de asociación y libre comercio
aunque las autoridades ucranianas
tendrán que esforzarse para acometer
reformas constitucionales de hecho la
crisis en ucrania se desencadenó
precisamente con la decisión del
presidente yanúkovich de suspender la
firma del acuerdo asociación y libre
comercio entre ucrania y la unión
europea en 2008 la guerra con georgia
tuvo también mucho que ver con la
intención de este país de adherirse a la
otan
bien los documentos en vigor también
reconocen como riesgos principales la
conversión de las ex repúblicas
soviéticas de asia central en estados
fallidos lo que impediría de facto que
sirviesen de zona buffer entre rusia y
la conflictiva zona de oriente medio de
hecho una de las situaciones de más
riesgos que vemos y contempla es el
contagio de esta región de mayoría
musulmana por el islamismo radical de
los yihadistas de seguiría ir a las
nuevas formas de guerra como es el caso
de los ciber conflictos también son
destacados en todos los informes
el manual de respuesta de rusia
y cómo se enfrenta a la rusia de putin a
todas estas amenazas pues os aseguro
amigos que este punto realmente
interesante en aras de obtener
legitimidad e incrementar su capacidad
de influencia útil ha convertido a las
minorías rusas de las diferentes
repúblicas exsoviéticas en un eje
central de su política exterior y
hablamos de una diáspora de más de 25
millones de personas en palabras de
putin los rusos se han convertido en la
nación más grande del mundo separadas
por fronteras de hecho el gobierno ruso
considera a la diáspora como un valioso
instrumento de política exterior pero
como se materializa el uso de la
diáspora pues por ejemplo lo que algunos
analistas denominan la estrategia de las
siete fases así cuando una de las
repúblicas exsoviéticas tiene la
tentación de acercarse a occidente o
enfrentarse a rusia el kremlin pone en
marcha como medida de presión este plan
tal y como ya vimos en georgia y ucrania
estas son las siete fases del plan de
moscú en la primera etapa impulsar los
lazos lingüísticos culturales y
religiosos que sean capaces de
incrementar los vínculos de la minoría
rusa con moscú
en segundo lugar proveer de asistencia
social a este grupo asistencia como
comida medicamentos o financiación e
inversiones económicas e intensa
e impulsar una comunidad completa y
diferenciada mediante la articulación de
instituciones propias y de una
estructura de representación y
movilización la cuarta etapa supone un
paso más la otorgación de la ciudadanía
rusa los miembros de la diáspora y por
su parte la quinta fase del plan se
centra en controlar a la información y
alimentar con ella las diferencias
existentes entre la población local y la
minoría rusa enfatizando por ejemplo
casos de discriminación alcanzando este
punto el gobierno ruso ha adquirido ya
una gran capacidad de influencia y
presión sobre el gobierno local que
observa como las estructuras sociales de
su país se desquebraja y crece la
conflictividad ahora bien cuando todo
ello no es suficiente
moscú pasa en la medida de lo posible a
la sexta y séptima etapa la asistencia y
protección a sus compatriotas la
imposición de sanciones económicas
políticas y comerciales y en última
instancia la intervención para el
ejercicio del control formal tal y como
ocurrió el crimen se trata en última
instancia de buscar un claro escarmiento
que disuada cualquier futuro cambio
político no alineado con sus intereses
el gasoducto está cerrado el gas ha
dejado de fluir desde rusia hacia
ucrania asimismo como mecanismo
preventivo
putin ha impulsado a
con pobres resultados la verdad la unión
euroasiática un proyecto de integración
económica y política algo así como la
unión europea de rusia de cara al resto
del mundo la apuesta de moscú pasa por
impulsar los lazos con potencias
regionales como china irán por ejemplo y
tal y como defiende el jefe del estado
mayor valer y gerásimos utilizar la
guerra híbrida como elemento de defensa
y poder atentos esto es valerse para
lograr sus objetivos de instrumentos no
convencionales escenarios de propaganda
y re informativa donde por ejemplo rt
juega un papel clave ejercer la guerra
económica apoyar las inestabilidades
locales o recurrir a los ciberataques
o piratas cibernéticos usos fueron los
responsables de haberles robado y
filtrado los correos electrónicos de el
comité nacional demócrata además no
podemos olvidar que más allá de una
política de defensa
putin ha sustentado su popularidad y lo
que algunos ya denominan el regreso del
imperio ruso así que nadie se lleva un
año amigos la tensión con rusia no se
terminará pronto bueno qué pensáis
vosotros continuará la creciente
utilidad con rusia veremos una nueva
guerra fría es efectiva la estrategia de
putin espero vuestros comentarios
si os ha gustado el vídeo no dudéis en
darle a like y suscribiros al canal un
saludo y hasta la próxima